منذ منتصف عام 2020 بعد شركه التسويق
العقاريه التي يديرها مارك بوليك سبعا من
اصل تسع شقق في هذه البنايه الفاخره وسط
لندن ارانا الرجل احدى الشقتين المتبقيتين
ثلاث غرف فاخره على مساحه 180 مترا مربعا
تقريبا يبلغ السعر الحالي نحو خمسه ملايين
جنيه استرليني رغم ان مثيلاتها بيعت
الواحده منها بقرابه سبعه ملايين منتصف
عام 2021 اما اكبر معدلات الهبوط فقد حدثت
خلال النصف الاخير من العام الماضي وهو
امر له ما يبرره براي ماركه
اعتقد ان سبب الاساسيه
قصيره وشاهدنا الميزانيه المصغره الكارثيه
في عهد وهذا كله ادى الى رفع معدله
الفائده بشكل كبير
وتظهر احصاءات الحكومه البريطانيه ان
متوسط اسعار العقارات السكنيه في عموم
البلاد تراجع في الاشهر السته الاخيره من
العام الماضي بشكل متواصل بنسبه تجاوزت
اثنين في المئه وتفيد تقديرات بنوك خاصه
ان الاتجاه النزولي استمر حتى نهايه شباط
فبراير الماضي وبهذا تصبح مده الهبوط
السعري للعقارات هي الاطول منذ الازمه
الماليه العالميه في عام 2008 التي امتدت
انذاك على مدار اربع سنوات
ويتناقض اداء القطاع العقاري حاليا مع
الانتعاش الذي شهده في عام 2020 في غمره
جائحه كورونا بسبب اعفاءات ضريبيه قدمتها
الحكومه لتحفيز السوق منعا للانهياره يكاد
محلل شؤون العقارات البريطانيون يتفقون
على ان بعض اسباب التراجع الحالي سياسيه
لكن يظل الوضع الاقتصادي حا بقوه في
المشهد
نفقات المعيشه تزيد والناس غير واثقين في
قدرتهم على تغيير مسكنهم وبعد الميزانيه
المصغره الكارثيه العام الماضي ارتفعت
فوائد القروض العقاريه بشده ما جعل الناس
عاجزين عن الحصول على التمويل اللازم
لشراء منزل اكبر او افضل وتظهر التجارب
التاريخيه ان العقارات في بريطانيا ظلت
دائما استثمارا جاذبا على المديين المتوسط
والبعيد ونتراجع الاسعار وانتفاقم يتحول
بعد انقشاع سحب الازمات الى ازدهار تعددوا
التقارير الاقتصاديه وتتعدد معها الرؤى
بشان مالات سوق العقاري في بريطانيا لكن
اعين الجميع تبقى مسلطه على جهود الحكومه
وعلى مدى فاعليه ميزانيتها الجديده
المتوقعه اعلانها منتصف هذا الشهر في كبح
جماح التضخم لكي تعود سوق العقاري الى
سابق ازدهارها
اسعد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن